so donald trump's former attorney
general william barr
is now coming out and saying all of
those election
lies trump was telling they were lies
they were bs he had these lawyers
working for him but the lawyers were a
quote clown show that's a quote from
william barr
and everybody now is saying here's a guy
willing to tell the truth about
guys he wrote a book he wrote a book and
now he wants to sell the book and like
everybody else he kept the most
interesting stories for the end now
did he actually
object
enough
to what was going on with donald trump
while he was working for him to say no
more well
only at the absolute end remember
william barr didn't resign until
december 23rd or something like that
of 2020
and he seemed to be wanting to get the
hell out of there before whatever was
gonna happen on january 6th happened but
he went along with it all along he was
willing to work for trump and on and on
and on and we can't let these guys be
rehabilitated but what william barr says
is really interesting
here is an interview that william barr
did with nbc nightly news host lester
holt where he says it was all bs and i
told him that all this stuff was blue
and
about election fraud
and
it was wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team was
and he started asking me about different
theories and i had the answers i was
able to tell him this is wrong because
of this you're trying to set him
straight yes and and and you know he
listened
he he was obviously getting very angry
about this i said okay well look i i
understand you're upset with me
and i'm perfectly happy to
tender my resignation and then boom he
slaps the desk he slapped the desk and
he said accepted accept it
and then boom he slapped it again accept
it
go home don't go back to your office go
home
you're done
so that is a firing folks now remember
that at the time
we were when this when this happened
when it was announced william barr is
leaving
we all understood
this this is a firing at this point in
all likelihood and indeed it was um and
uh it is just another one of these
examples where
some see this and say what what a great
guy what a hero william barr willing to
tell the truth he's willing to tell the
truth uh what is it 15 months later
because he's trying to sell a book would
have been useful to hear this stuff at
the time and uh there is another segment
of this interview uh where he talks
about the clown show of lawyers that
donald trump brought out and it was
quite a clown show
and
about election fraud
and uh
it was wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team was
and then he also told trump what he
thought of his legal team
not a lot
i said the reason you are where you are
is because you wheeled out a clown show
of lawyers
a clown show yeah clown car or something
like that i said it's just a bunch of
clowns
who are you referring to
rudy giuliani's the cracker jack legal
team and my lovers mars says the
president shot back listening so guys
obviously barr is right and it's funny
to hear him talk about those clown
lawyers in these terms but
he was complicit with so much of what
went on for so long he misstated what
was in the mueller report you know he's
not a good guy ways he said barr had
failed him that's when barr says he
offered up his resignation i said okay
well look i understand you're upset with
me
and i'm perfectly happy to
tender my resignation and then boom he
slaps the desk he slapped the desk and
he said accepted
accept it which we heard already boom he
slapped it again accept it
go home don't go back to your office go
home
you're done
when we asked the former president about
this meeting he disputed barr's account
and told us he was the one who demanded
barr's resignation
either way barr handed in a resignation
either way it was a firing letter two
weeks later and has not spoken with
donald trump since
he does not want him to run for
president again
all right
so listen why is william barr doing this
now uh it's because he wrote a book and
he wants to sell a book and there's this
uh sort of rehabilitation tour
and um maybe part of it is also
distancing from trump for future
opportunities or whatever but it's
almost certainly just to sell a book
that's the that's the theme they hold on
to the juicy stuff or their indignant
and principled statements until they
have a book to sell i think they mostly
do tell the truth william barr or
whoever stephanie grisham wrote one and
now i don't even remember all the people
who have written books it's just at a
particular time for a particular benefit
they start telling all of those stories
now the other aspect of this is
any opportunity that trump has to talk
about barr trump will almost certainly
throw a bar under the bus so it's like
why hold back at this point anyway but
remember barr is not a good guy it's
like hey mitt romney said one thing that
makes sense but he's still a guy i don't
really agree with politically
all of the former trump people are worse
because they worked for trump
um barr
lied to congress with regard to
important parts of the mueller report he
he lied in that letter that he put out
remember the letter
summarizing the mueller report which
wrongly said that it
cleared trump of obstruction which the
mueller report very clearly did not so
if you're actually interested in this
book i'd wait a few weeks it almost
certainly will show up in the 99 cent
area within a few weeks or a couple
months that's almost always the way it
happens with these political books i
will not be buying the book and uh what
in terms of the movement that barr is
now part of
i would be willing to concede that barr
seems to be exiting the worst of the
worst trumpian fringe sure he he resigns
slash was fired he calls out bs when he
sees it okay fine
but he's taking a step back
to the pence mcconnell republican party
which is almost as bad it's people who
are
in denial about this being donald
trump's party it's clueless people it's
people who were willing to go with
whatever trump wanted for as long as it
was sort of beneficial to them and gave
them access to centers of power or
whatever the case may be
he's marginally less crazy i guess
because he's willing to say this so for
all we know they're bailing on trump
because they plan to build consensus
around
republicans nominating some kind of
centrist
in 2024 instead of someone like a trump
or a desantis but these are not good
people and william barr deserves barely
any praise william barr has done one
percent of of all that william barr has
done
um since working for trump as attorney
general one percent of what he said and
done makes sense and seems sort of like
morally grounded and so he can get that
one percent praise from us good thing
he's saying this he's saying it now to
sell books and i wouldn't trust this guy
as far as i can throw him one of our
long time sponsors is vincero collective
i love vincero's watches you've heard me
talk about them before they now offer
sunglasses and a bunch of other premium
accessories for men and women vincero is
committed to creating exceptionally
crafted watches and accessories and
doing so ethically fair pricing carbon
neutrality vincero puts their principles
first which is important to me i just
picked up the rogue from vincero in
gunmetal and red i love the intricate
design on the watch face and the
multiple sub dials the durable black
silicone strap looks great with just
about anything i'm wearing in all of
vincero's products whether it's the
watches the glasses men's or women's you
can just see and feel the quality so if
you want to elevate your look or you
want to find the perfect valentine's day
gift for that special someone pick
something up at vincero vincero
collective is giving my audience 15
off all products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below